les femmes sont-elles sous payés à la
télé j'ai commencé par maxime parce que
je sais que tu as le top des salaires
des animateurs ce qu'on connaît du mans
on va commencer par ça exactement alors
dans le top 10 des animateurs les mieux
payés en france force est de constater
qu'il n'ya pas de femmes dans le top 3
mais or il ya jean luc reichmann qui est
quand même il ya une visibilité
quotidienne avec une audience qui n'a
pas baissé en l'espace de dix ans
ensuite c'est nagui alors attention à ce
sont des sommes qui ne comprennent pas
forcément toutes leurs activités
parallèles d'investissement
la présentation d'une émission salaire
mensuel exactement laurent itier
finalement la première femme c'est
karine le marchand avec 30000 euros on
peut pas dire que les femmes à la
télévision sont sous payés parce que ce
sont des sommes énormes même chose pour
marie sophie lacarrau qui est acquis au
jt 13h en face son collègue et julien
budget est beaucoup moins payer parce
que c'est sur le service public merci
coopération parce qu'il ya des grilles
de salaire en fonction de la case de la
chaîne de la notoriété et en cela c'est
ce qui fait l équilibre et pour répondre
juste pour les miss france parce que
c'était le début du lieu du débat ce
n'est pas un emploi mais un concours et
de ce fait alexia laroche-joubert la
productrice a tout à fait raison opaque
l'argent ça devienne une priorité bien
sûr faire se tient ce concours malongo
mais dans ce cas là je me trompe sa peau
le journaliste médias les candidats de
télé réalité sont aussi payés ils sont
payés parce que c'est un job mais ils
font pas de concours mais je suis désolé
mais être candidate à miss france vu ce
que ça implique l'exposition le cyber
harcèlement qui est possible après eh
ben je suis désolé c'est aussi un job et
pour le concours qui se dit maintenant
féministe est bien là le premier acte de
féminisme ce serait peut-être de bien
payer les candidates et une chose on
parlait tout à l'heure de ce qui s'est
passé à la bbc avec samira ahmed qui
étaient payés donc 100 euros quand
l'autre était payé 3500 la justice a
constaté donc la discrimination par le
genre ce qui est bien c'est que l à la
hulpe cet accord financier avec la bbc
dont elle a pu prendre son oseille ça
c'est très cool mais surtout il ya 700
employés et es femmes de la bbc qui ont
pu avoir une augmentation de salaire
grâce à
la diète d'ailleurs vous êtes miss vous
avez participé à miss monde d'accord
avec toi avec tout le respect que j'ai
pour toi parce que
non elle n'est pas d'accord avec eux
malek au fond et je vais dire pourquoi
je vais argumenté parce qu'en fait déjà
pour revenir aux miss moins pour moi
quand tu fais un concours de ban
tu le fais parce que tu as envie de le
faire étape à être payés ou avoir des
sommes astronomiques et là où je vais
argumenté c'est qu'elle se plaignent de
touche et 3000 euros par mois mais ça le
genre mois et non arrivée en touchant
l'allocation adulte handicapé à me
plaindre a touché 900 euros pour vivre
par mon bon alors que je survis c'est
très vrai c'est le nid najet parce que
sur le sur la polémique nice france on
parlait de ses 84 euros par jour qui
étaient en fait des jours de tournage
mais miss france une fois qu'elle est
élue elle a effectivement comme l'a dit
najet 3000 euros par mois à peu près
c'est un salaire
50 et le condamne l appartement de
fonction dans le 16e arrondissement
paris dont elle n'a pas de loyer et elle
est dotée sur et que c'est tel bijou
des conditions pour terminer après pour
revenir à les femmes sont sous payés à
la télé je suis un peu partagé je
rejoins maxime et le reste de l'équipe
ça dépend de ce que tu fais ça dépend de
ta notoriété faire des pins de la chaîne
ça dépend de plein de choses donc je
dirais oui et non après on a évolué par
rapport à ça parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
femmes aujourd'hui à l'antenne la plus
avancée que vous à gâteau les présenter
en avance je veux dire on peut pas tout
avoir d'un coup parce qu'ils gèrent deux
mots là-dessus sur les miss c'est un
scandale elles n'étaient pas payés avant
aujourd'hui à vienne 84 euros par jour
pas de quoi s plein il ya des
intermittents c'est le minimum syndical
et pour revenir sur le salaire générale
des ddd femme marie sophie lacarrau
certes elles viennent beaucoup mais
quand on compare à gilles bouleau voilà
on regarde le salaire de gilles bouleau
sur tf1 marc et sophie la sophie
lacarrau hagan de 13h et 20h sinon pas
là elle est venue globalement plus
globalement franchement c'est assez
inégal et il faut vraiment travailler là
dessus et que ce soit à la télé ou
ailleurs il ya une vraie inégalité et ça
c'est pas
77 % de moins quand même les 17% moins
que les hommes en moyenne là ça c'est un
problème de société le systémique
structurelles mais pour parler de la
télé je sais pas si la télé le meilleur
exemple pour illustrer cela maintenant
je pense pas parce que la télé c'est
véritablement enfin moi ça fait 25 ans
que je fais ça et c'est vrai que
l'expérience qui compte il ya
effectivement la notoriété main sacs en
carrière pour sophie koch
avait 20 ans quand j'ai commencé sur m6
et c'est vrai qu'à l'époque je me disais
que je veux gagner super bien ma vie
j'avais 20 ans je gagnais très bien ma
vie et après c'est vrai que je suis
d'accord avec je crois que c'est magali
berda convoi dans le reportage
effectivement par exemple sur des
métiers d'image même si encore
aujourd'hui les actrices sont moins bien
payés que les acteurs ont télévision et
par exemple sur les réseaux sociaux sur
instagram etc les femmes sont mieux
payés et dans man qui m'a d'ailleurs
aussi sont mieux payées que les hommes
par exemple je prends un exemple qui me
vient à l'idée puisqu'on est sur ces 8
mais je pense je m'avance peut être un
peu mais je pense que sûreté pmp c'est
une femme qui est la mieux payée
j'obtiens et qui sait
juste la vie de charlotte quand même sur
cette question alors oui en moi la
première qu'avant je prescris je suis
pas payé non je rigole plus sérieusement
au même titre que les concurrents de
miss france voilà moi je fais ça pour
l'expérience pour les opportunités et
c'est donc moi ça me choque pas que les
miss france soit pas bien payé je veux
dire je pense un mauvais raccourci que
de parler du salaire générale des femmes
à la télé en comparant ce de miss france
après je pense que les femmes à la télé
trop souvent elles sont réduites à leurs
attributs physiques et non
intellectuelle par exemple moi je dois à
mon niveau dans 90% des commentaires
c'est jasper physique ou mon look alors
que quand je suis contre des mecs genre
sans sexisme et c'est là où anthony n'y
avait aucun commentaire comme ça sur eux
moi je me dis c'est quand même le fossé
mais ça y va pas y avoir les mêmes
commentaires mais je l'avais annoncé
informatique dans celle
qui regarde les politiques achats maroc
est une femme politique qui met un
tailleur ou un truc et c'est aussi le jt
un air
saturé sur son comment elle s'habille
comme elle se maquille pour venir à bout
de ces analyses et de ses prières câble
ça décrédibilise des femmes forcément
qui dit moins de crédibilité dit moins
bien payés et faut en finir avec cette
foire était de chez les femmes sur leur
physique sur leur look quand elles sont
chroniqueuse veut dire mais là je suis
là en tant que chroniqueuse part en tant
que des corps même qu'un état membre a
raison moi on m'a déjà dit par exemple
que si j'étais trop maquillée salle est
décrédibilisé mois en cours mais c'est
pas normal c'est pas normal d'entendre
ce genre de choses
comment donner les devants juste pour
compléter évidemment que si on compare
au salaire moyen des français qui
galèrent qui survivent juste de leur
travail oui non mais finalement que
c'est indécent et ça j'en suis bel et
bien conscient par contre si on prend
juste karine le marchand et et tous les
autres salaires enfin le plus haut
salaire c'est 125 milles elle est à 30
mètres je crois bah voila je sais c'est
les crèches mais n'ont cessé d'être 6e
j'en écrivais je voulais me dit à la
télé karine le marchand est là pas une
quotidienne tous les milieux 225000
travaille tous les jours du lundi je
vais faire je vais faire mon beauf de
service mais ce sont les médias privés
je m'en fiche un peu oui mais sur
l'audiovisuel public on paye une
redevance je trouve qu'en fait les
salaires des présentateurs des
animateurs devraient être rendues
publiques en toute transparence parce
que c'est aussi notre argent et on verra
s'il ya des écarts ou pas et ça incitera
peut-être je ne sais pas peut-être
france télévisions et radio france a
aidé c'est une très bonne idée mais
on les paye pas c'est le seul avantage
que tu en lumière les redevances télé
ouais bah tout compris mais
harper ou banon
après devenir général si les femmes qui
ont des mêmes compétences que les hommes
sont moins bien payés que et que c'est
prouvé oui alors les femmes est sûre si
ça se base sur la seule console à
l'école son intention que ces pays si
elles sont sous payés par rapport aux
hommes oui elles sont sous payés il n'y
a pas de débat sur la presse a dépeint
le métier que tu fais là on parle plus
médiatique c'est vrai que dans le monde
de tous les jours dans le monde dans
lequel on vit oui il ya des femmes à son
souper situe à
5 % de
paris les états unis par exemple aux
états unis ellen degeneres oprah winfrey
qui sont de très grandes animatrices de
torchon elles sont beaucoup mieux payés
que jimmy fallon jimmy kimmel qui eux
aussi sont très très établie aux états
unis qui ont le temps chaud qui sont les
des stars littéralement mais les femmes
sont beaucoup mieux payées que les
hommes ont raison sur elles sont
honnêtement 1 dégénère s et oprah
winfrey show elle savait pas alors c'est
au dessus y a personne au dessus donc
voilà donc c'est cela c'est la valeur et
c'est le talent mes parents je pense que
là c'est pas genre et c'est que je vois
pas qui peut leur arriver au dessus
alors c'est vrai le maire que leurs
différences elles sont uniques en leur
genre et donc là on est juste que le
talent est pas forcément le physique on
les aime pour ce qu'elles sont et ce
qu'elles dégagent
ça veut dire qu'en france les femmes on
voit talent c'est satan train dans l'axé
mais bien sûr
[Applaudissements]
et très brillant mais un jour par
rapport à ta remarque est en train de
dire qu'en france les femmes n'ont pas
n'ont pas de talent
mal gamme et
là dessus